hey what's going on it's Bill bur it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you I'm just
checking in on you I already recorded
this podcast but the microphone was
hooked up to my headphones so now I have
to do it again and the old me oh the old
me would get [__] pissed off and
guess what the new me still gets pissed
off oh my God I cursed out dead Steve
Jobs cuz I know what the [__] they're
doing oh I I know what they're doing
they're [__] with me right now cuz
they want me to buy the new goddamn
phone can you believe these [__]
politicians they just allow a company to
literally sabotage their own [__]
product you know what I mean it'd be
like if somebody made a [__] car you
know and it was designed to [__] die
at 60,000 miles and the speedometer only
went up to 80 miles oh wait we did that
we did that in the
80s it's not a new
thing
um anyway
congratulations to the Minnesota
Twins this is the funniest expression
I've ever heard in my life in sports
with a two game
sweep what in the [__] is a two game s
best two out of three oh they swep them
you don't get swept in a three-game
series okay that's not a sweep they got
to call it something else a bump you got
bumped you know what I mean that's not a
sweep a sweep has to be at least three
games in a [__] row anybody can lose
two in a row right and the goddamn Twins
win [__] win the series sweep them
two games to none they take a team
[__] photo and they're drinking
champagne you know for the love of a
juicy locy there why don't you guys act
like you're [__] been there before
there's still like 17 more [__]
rounds before you even get to the ALCS
what are you
doing I don't know Bill we were sort of
enjoying
ourselves
um anyway I am in Niagara Falls
Niagara Niagara Falls I crossed the
Canadian border yesterday I'll tell you
what was amazing you know we go through
the border and it was just like you guys
don't got any [__] weed or anything
we got no no we don't sorry just [__]
did one those talking burps there it's
like yeah no we don't and uh we were
sitting there you know in the [__]
office and
[__] and they're on the bus going
through my stuff and I look over at
Kenny and I'm like oh [__] he's like
what I got got half a joint in my bag I
forgot somebody gave it to me on the
[__]
road
and he just shakes his head and I'm just
like yeah you know what are we going to
do there's either going to be a show or
there isn't and they came back they
didn't see it they're cool they're
Canadian it's half a joint
so
um it was sort of a funny little moment
then I was just thinking the whole [__]
well the [__] if I was in Singapore that
would have been a life goddamn sentence
this is why I don't like weed you know
what I mean I like how it makes you feel
but you forget that you have it right
and you always end up in these goddamn
situations
um but anyway I also wanted to talk
about the [__] Baltimore Orioles my
playoff team your Baltimore Orioles I'm
so excited they won over a 100 games
this year they won the um the AL East
which is not an easy division to win the
amount of money the [__] Yankees and
Red Sox spend every year how great in
organization the uh the Devil Rays are
I'll always call them the Devil Rays the
nerve of people in Florida to act like
they're not to the Devil with the lives
that they lead maybe it's just too
redundant you
know you had the devil down there you
[__] had elron hubber the devil's
been there a bunch of
times um anyway uh the latest devil I
should say I don't know who started the
the Catholic
religion there's so many crazy
theories you know usually comes back to
like homosexuality that they were all
gay and they were trying to hide it and
stuff like that it's a really dark dark
[__] you know if you do it about
anything you know even if you like Cheez
itss you really don't want to go back in
history and see all the blood money
behind those tasty little snacks do you
you know it's just better to just keep
plowing forward and just be like hey you
know a lot of [__] up [__] happen
happened but I didn't do it I wasn't
there all
right I'll go to church I'll eat some
Cheez itss afterwards you
know I'll go solicit some prostitution
you know to keep that business going
money in Money out right keeps the
circle going I don't even know what I'm
talking about the [__] Baltimore
Orioles I don't think that they've won
the AL East last time I remember them
winning it was
um they must have won it some other time
then
I just know the World Series champions
84 was the Tigers 85 was the Royals 86
was the Mets 87 was the twins 88 was the
Dodgers 89 was the A's 90 was the
Reds I don't but I don't know who
[__] won those divisions back then
certainly wasn't the Red
Soxs um although maybe I want to say we
won an 86 or an 80 we won an 86
obviously was the last of the Mets now
here I go [__] Beautiful Mind [__]
baseball version 89 I want to say we
lost to the
A's I don't [__] know nickas
saski um
anyway I'm very excited for the
Baltimore Orioles they were a Powerhouse
when I was growing up great pitching
Frank
Tanana Jim
Palmer then they had out in the field
they had Eddie Murray oh my God Eddie
Murray 500 legit over 500 legit home
runs when when you went up there like a
[__]
man no HGH no steroids no elbow pad Shin
pad [__] chin walking up there
looking like half a football player like
a Dick Tracy character he playing
baseball is he playing football he
walked up there with whatever he had for
breakfast and [__] knocked it out of
the goddamn Park and trotted around the
bases like a goddamn man not [__]
punching himself in the chest screaming
let's go and all that stupid [__]
musical theater [__] all these [__]
athletes do nowadays it drives me up the
[__] wall especially in baseball it's
such a slow moving game it's like
watching somebody [__] like talking
[__] on 10 while sitting there smoking a
cigar everyone else is around standing
around like you know when you watch
baseball it's a guy hits a ball and it's
usually just one person moving if it's
in the infield one person moves and then
the first baseman steps on a bag there's
really not a lot going on Short Stop and
second baseman just watching the play go
over you know I know there little things
cut off men and covering bases but like
I I really don't understand it all this
let's go [__] um oh yeah I'm going to be
Billy Old
Man Billy old man right now as I look at
Niagra Falls I have on the Canadian side
you know where they got this [__]
this hilar
ious like sky doome looking thing called
the
skyon and it looks like the [__]
Russians built it in
Yugoslavia it's got that brutalism Vibe
which I didn't even know what that [__]
was called To be honest with you I
didn't really even see it there wasn't a
lot of pictures from behind the Iron
Curtain there I mean we knew about the
Steel Curtain am I right we didn't know
about the Iron Curtain what was behind
it and they just had like these
uh I mean it looks like it's out of a
[__] movie like how the [__] did
Communism think that they were going to
work treating people like that I mean
it's okay to be a be a government and
[__] your own people in the ass just
look what happens in capitalism but you
got to make it look pretty you need a
mascot you need some pretty colors you
don't make every building look like you
[__] you know put some windows on a
parking garage whatever the hell they
were doing I mean it was so [__] you the
style
brutalism I mean that's one of the
[__] baddest names ever for you know
this is like a midcentury you
know this is
brutalism if you can [__] live here
you can [__] live anywhere
um anyway so I I got a view of the falls
both of them I I'm going to I'm going to
take a video I'm going to I'm going to
I'm going to post it on my
uh my Instagram stories there and this
is what kills me like this is this is
like one of the most beautiful things
things I've ever
seen and as great as it is all that
footage people were taken from the
sphere in Las Vegas like I that's one of
the most unbelievable [__] things
I've ever seen in my life and it's not
even real but it is real but what
they're what they're projecting isn't
really there but it's there but it's not
what you're seeing but you're seeing it
you know what I mean I mean the [__] was
so [__] unbelievable they turned you
two one of the biggest bands of the last
40 years they were like some wedding
band playing over in the corner that no
one's listening to you know what he
haded sharing you know that's
like is he the son of the guy from
Simply Red I think the math works on
that they got to be cousins or something
both incredible
singers you know beautiful voices I
can't believe I I I was just such a
[__] [__] growing up when I was
listening to metal when I heard like
simply red when I heard him sing that
song lady in red I know that's not him
whatever he was singing Whatever the
[__] song he was singing I'll keep
hold it on
right I was like this song is slow and
makes me feel feelings I'm not
comfortable with this guy's gay I'm not
listening to this it was so stupid now I
listen back to him like this guy's one
of the best [__] voices I've ever
heard Oh Billy homophobe when he was
young um it what it really was was like
if I play this song in my car I'm going
to get the [__] kicked out of me when I
get out of
it yeah be careful Massachusetts was an
angry place as opposed to what bill is
it nice now I don't know so anyway I'm
[__] watching this [__] video that
these kid these goddamn kids with their
[__] phones and it's
like the the level of
overstimulation I think if you went to
that concert if you saw Niagara Falls
you'd be like eh you
know how come there's not other [__]
being projected in the sky while I look
at Niagara Falls how come I can't watch
like how come I can't travel through the
[__]
Universe I mean like once you see a
concert there you
[__] like the i i the footage of some
of the stuff that they were projecting
and it just goes completely all the way
over you like do you realize the level
of drugs we had to do to see half of
that [__] at the wor the Centrum back in
the
day that's what killed me about the
footage the footage had nothing to do
with YouTu that could have been a
YouTube cover band I wonder what I would
love to hear what they're thinking I
mean they're such a business at this
point they'd probably be like you know
it's fantastic it's just adding another
layer to the [__] we're peeling
another layer off the onion you know
backstage they got to be going like you
know whatever they [__] say over
there
oi right that's the end of us who gives
a [__] now nobody
cares I don't want to you're I'm just
going to see you like one of the great
bands of the last 40 years I'm just
going to see you that's all there
is I don't get to [__] sit there on
mushrooms and have an eagle fly off of
the ceiling sit down next to me put it
feathered Wing around me and start
talking to me about why America's great
before I take it by its non-existent
hand and I start flying over the
band I'd love I if I live long enough I
can't wait to hear this generation
talking down to the Next
Generation like this isn't a concert man
back when I you know when I went to a
concert you know it was just you the
band in the entire history of the world
experienced in first person Vision
flying over your head we didn't have an
AI robot blowing us while it was
[__] growing
mushrooms in a compartment on its back
that you could continue taking you kids
are spoiled today um yeah I feel like
that they're building another sphere cuz
now everybody has to try and compete
with that and I feel like well maybe not
maybe it'll be like IMAX people still go
to movies sort
of um
I don't
know I never thought I would see
something that would could possibly make
people think that Red Rocks was only
okay I like to think that people will
still think those places are off that's
the place you got to go dude [__] the
sphere all right that's going to be
there forever and it's going to get old
really C really quick cooking out there
in the desert you know it's kind of like
that big stupid TV that they have at at
the Dallas Cowboy stadium like when did
they just just going to admit that that
was the dumbest idea it was just the
stupidest [__] idea it was really was
Dallas you know there biggest [__] TV
there's ever
been I'll tell you what my wife's got
the biggest titties
too she didn't have them at the
beginning of the relationship you know
what I mean I'm taking care of her I got
her them nice titties too that hang
realize you know what I mean you know
what it is it's her own body fat I had
it sucked out of her belly you know she
went too many Pig pickings and I said
take it out of there and stick it in
there right and is there any way you
could you know make her mouth only open
if it's going around my dick CU I'm
really sick of her opinions it's why
I've been married three times um I used
to tease them at the Dallas improv
saying like you realize that okay that
TV's cool now but in seven years you're
going to have the biggest old [__] TV
that no one gives a [__]
about they must have done something
where they can can keep updating it but
um I guess I understand why I actually
don't understand why they did it because
it's the most distracting thing I've
ever seen and if you sit in the upper
deck you're not even going to watch the
you're just going to sit there watching
the [__] TV so then it becomes why
did I go to this and that's also like
when I look at the sphere it's like I
can just put on you uh
YouTube on my phone play it through a
speaker and I can take a nice handful of
mushrooms
and have the same [__]
experience because I really feel like
when you I don't know maybe I got to go
to a show there but it was it was like
you two wasn't even there they were like
an
afterthought you know how can you listen
to Bono talking about how he knows how
to save the world you know if you're too
busy flying over the [__] Ander
rondex you know from there to Abu
Dhabi while you're on
mushrooms was Bono up there like Roy
hey just checking in with the
band don't know if you ever heard of us
um you know what sucks is
uh I have no desire to go to that thing
and I but I know I'm going to end up
there because I love my wife and she's
totally into stuff like that like oh
it's going to be [__] it was [__]
amazing it was so cool and then I'm
going to [__] on it and then she's just
going to look at me and be like what's
wrong with you like why why can't you
just enjoy things it's like I do enjoy
things I just don't enjoy things like
this you know and then the logic of that
is not going to hook up with their
female brain and then the emotion of
what she's talking about is not going to
hook up with my [__] logical
brain then it'll be awkward and then
I'll say I'm sorry and she'll say okay
and then we'll go over to Roy Choice
like that's what's going to [__]
happen but did you notice in that story
at no point did I ever even bring up
what band we're going to go see cuz I
don't think it matters probably see some
early '90s
hip-hop R&B
artist you know that's Nia's wheelhouse
that's her hair metal stiff s with
voices Al de
barge um inv Vogue Boys to
Men
Usher jodessy I don't know I can't I I
know all that music I can't name any of
those songs but I have been with my
lovely wife who I missed terribly out
here for almost 20 years so I've heard
all of that music um all right let's do
a little bit of the advertising I have
to go a little short this week I
apologize because I already recorded
this podcast but I had my stupid [__]
Bose headphones on and it was going
through that it wasn't Steve Jobs there
I admit it all right but it's
convenient he's an Inconvenient Truth
that I can blame him and he's dead so he
can't defend himself I mean that's kind
of Perfect all right so here's here's
the live reads here um all right Simply
Safe
everybody well it's official I can't
have kids sorry Debbie Downer well it's
official fall is here if you're like me
you're settling back into B busier
routines with the kids at school and
Spare Time filled with soccer practices
and seasonal activities your home may be
sitting empty and vulnerable that's why
I recommend Simply Safe home security
and their revolutionary home monitoring
Innovations 24/7 lifeguard protection
it's designed to help stop crime in real
time now if an intruder breaks into your
home Simply Safe professionals
monitoring agents can actually see speak
to and deter them through simply safes
new Smart Alarm Wireless indoor camera
here's my only question about that if
they can see the Intruder can't they
also watch you banging your wife like
how does that work how do they turn it
on and turn it off does the camera only
turn on if the [__] alarm that has to
be that did the Cable Guy figure out a
back door around it so he can watch you
give you way oh Jesus 247 liveu
protection is made possible by the new
Smart Alarm Wireless indoor camera
available with fast protur
monitoring um plan the new Smart Alarm
indoor camera is the only indoor
security camera that can trigger the
alarm and instantly deter Intruders with
a built-in siren it has it has physical
privacy shutter to provide protection
when you need it oh there it is and
privacy when you want it there it is
right there okay 24/7 liveu protection
and the new Smart Alarm but can't
somebody go around that don't these
nerds always build something I don't
know I still throw a face cloth over the
camera before I got busy right H look at
me hip hop ad Jason before I got jiggy
with it 24/7 lifeguard protection and
the new Smart Alarm indoor camera Works
seamlessly as part of the Simply Safe
system to keep your whole home safe from
break-ins fires floods and more install
your way do it yourself in about 30
minutes to have a Simply Safe expert set
it up for you either way it's easy to
protect your home for a limited time get
20% off your new system when you sign up
for fast protect monitoring visit
simplysafe
m p l i s a f e there's no safe like
Simply
Safe oh look who it is everybody would
you look who it is it's old
zip
recruiter uh right now I'd like to give
a shout out to all those people whose
job it is to hire from the small
businesses owners growing their team to
the [__] CEO [__] that are re
ruining this country right all you
corporate bastards
uh sorry to the HR directors hiring
hundreds across the Nations you have one
of the toughest jobs there is but what
if I were to tell you there's something
that can make your whole hiring process
faster and easy easier it's zip
yes uh recruiter brandan right now you
can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com
bur zip recruiter is trusted by millions
so you don't have to worry
zip recruiter has helped make hiring
faster and easier for bus businesses of
all sizes in fact over 3.8 million
businesses have come to zip recruited
for their hiring needs Hiring Heroes
Hiring
Heroes like the Super Friends let zip
help make your job easier four to five
employers have post unzip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the First
first day see for yourself go to this
exclusive web address to try
zip uh for free ziprecruiter.com bur
that again ziprecruiter.com bur spellout
bur B RR
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire oh
my God that's my favorite thing I mean
I'm just like like a perfect golf
swing the way I let that thing go by the
way did anybody see Dave port noise um
one bite everybody knows the rule Pizza
Festival how the [__] did I not
know that that was happening cuz if you
watch that thing basically he he's gone
around to all of these places so you try
to make a list of the ones that had the
top you know the top ratings by
him right and he he he grades very hard
so if he gets anything in the nines you
know it's it's absolutely delicious but
the problem is is it's all spread out of
spread out all over hell so what does
bar stool sports do they have a giant
pizza event and they're going to start
doing it every year and I'm telling you
right now there's no [__] way that
I'm going to miss that thing next year I
going to be there because there's that
one place the uh The Brick Oven place
out in New Jersey that got the highest
rating I hate that he didn't give it a
10 but I also love that he didn't give
it a 10
because that it
like if he gives it a 10 then then you
just stop you found you're at the
mountain peak you want to keep going up
you want to keep [__] going up did
anybody see that video of that [__]
lady trying to climb Mount Everest and
she was [__]
screaming she's like oh my God screaming
because hikers climbers mountain
climbers above
her had like passed out from the
altitude and they were just dead they
were dead they were sliding down like
their snowsuits became like sleds and
these just these dead bodies are sliding
down the mountain she's going oh my God
oh my God oh my my God and I don't know
why people just put deliberately putting
themselves into perilous situations it
just makes me laugh I'm like what the
[__] did you think was going to
happen what did you think was going to
[__] happen how many dead bodies have
you passed on the way up there I know
but I didn't think I would see it
happen swim with sharks see what the
[__]
happens have you guys seen that video of
that [__] guy swimming in the ocean
that somebody's like in a helicopter and
this [__] shark swims in around the
guy and starts speeding up and at the
last second it swims
away I mean people who swim in the
[__] ocean are just out of their [__]
in the amount of times that's probably
happened and you don't even know it oh
my
God I
mean who wants to drown nobody who wants
to be eaten alive nobody who wants to
combine those two horrific [__]
deaths evidently this [__] jerk off
in his goddamn
Speedo what do you I
mean and you always you right near the
you can see the
shore you can see where this thing
doesn't live and doesn't survive I swear
to God you swim in the [__] ocean
it's literally like walking into a
jungle and then sticking your head into
the [__] sand and hoping something
doesn't walk by and take a [__] bite
out of you you're out of your mind I am
a pool guy I don't even [__] with Lakes
I've been sitting here looking at nager
Falls here
man and I'm waiting for somebody to fall
out of a [__] boat look at that and
they got a nice uh everybody has on life
jacket see that's my [__] right there if
you ever wonder what my [__] was that's
my [__] right there um all right that's
the podcast everybody I got to uh I
gotta I gotta upload some video of this
um I also got to do a show tonight also
got to get my [__] together there's a
lot of [__] I got to do here but you
know I've been working out I've been
working out I feel good feel good you
know you come home you know you look a
little skinnier look a little more
jacked your wife sees it right she
starts thinking what you been up to us
maybe maybe I'll [__] show you right
talk a little [__] have a good
time and then you go back out the next
weekend and then you [__] up right I got
to take video of these stupid they
literally this this [__] skyon
thing what they're bringing people up on
outside the
place the elevator it looks like one of
those dietary pills the original ones
like the 1970s you know when women used
to wear panty hoose and they were sort
of like addicted to like [__] diet
pills you
know guys were all like [__]
alcoholics smoking cigars and riding a
[__] horse cuz you thought it made
you a man I got to take a picture of
this [__] all right I'm uploading this
[__] uh you guys have a great weekend
you come and I will see all of you on
Monday I won't see you but I will I will
be doing a podcast all right that's it
bet responsibly on the NFL don't be a
[__] [__] have fun with it don't let
these [__] take all your money all
[Music]
right hey what's going on it's Bill Burr
and it's time for the Monday Morning
podcast for Monday October 5th 2015 15
uh you're going to have to deal with
this this is the level of talking that
I'm going to be able to do because I
have a couple of guests here in my house
and it's uh 8:00 a.m. and I'm trying to
be courteous unlike the [__] that called
me at 6:58 in the morning I thought it
was some [__] radio guy you know for
some gig I had back East I had no idea
was like how you doing
this I was like uh what and he was like
I guess my wife sched some [__] [__]
here at the house on Sund uh Saturday
she wasn't even aware of
it I don't something about the [__]
alarm he goes is there any way I can
reschedule
it it's like well
uh I don't know about this what I got to
wait till my wife wakes up and he goes
oh okay sounds like I woke you up too
it's like yeah it's 6:58 in the morning
you
[__] with your [__] morning DJ voice
hey it's Eddie and the bulldog we got
bill coming up here in a bit as he's
going to be doing two shows here in
Maryland um sorry that was a bad morning
DJ voice but you know something I'm I'm
trying to be courteous to the other
people in the [__] house here all
right whatever let's plow through the
podcast here uh I got to say something I
got to get something right off right off
my old freckled [__] chest
here uh to start this thing all right
the W Hotel I am [__] done with that
place had a great weekend right I did a
couple of Ben benefits out in uh
DC and
um won the tig Naro setup for the uh
Planned Parenthood and it was such a
[__] cool crowd my whole set I just
kept telling them that they didn't like
babies what my favorite things to do
when you do a benefit is you go out
there and then you act like you don't
understand the point of view of the
people that are doing the benefit unless
it's something [__] horrific you know
what I mean like if it's you know kids
with cancer or something like that then
I behave myself but if it's like Planned
Parenthood or uh you know the right to
life if it was the right to life people
I would tease them that they' haven't
looked at a census and how many people
are on the
planet um hey let's keep having more
babies I would just do something like
that something anything to just kind of
kill the [__] tension of the one
subject that you're not supposed to talk
about so
um it was just an awesome crowd and I
kept going back to that and they had a
great sense of humor about themselves
they kept laughing when I was saying it
um you know the rest of my act it was a
little touchy DC is really [__]
touchy by the way if you if what I found
if you perform at the DC Improv though
it's a great crowd you get a couple of
uptight people there or whatever but
like if once you uh get out of the clubs
and it becomes a bigger event like that
benefit that was at like a theater it's
just this really
weird sort of um pay attention to what
you laugh at kind of thing like it's it
feels like a political fundraiser for
whatever [__] reason but uh Friday
night they were cool and then on
Saturday um did the addiction benefit
that uh Mary and Geraldo Greg geraldo's
wife put together and uh Jesus Christ
what a [__] show that was everybody
murdering Tom Papa putting on a clinic
nick
depalo uh Judy gold TIG was on that one
too Gary Owen I mean it was just a
[__] just a monster show I know I'm
going to forget a few people but uh
everybody was what was really cool was
just a bunch of different styles and
everybody with their own style
absolutely [__] destroyed and uh dude
I got to tell you something Nick depalo
man he's probably the most underrated
comedian out there man if if that guy's
playing in your area you got to go see
him he's [__] if you want to see just
like completely
uncensored somebody just saying exactly
what they're thinking uh that's the guy
to go see and uh he does not take an
ounce of [__] from anyone in the crowd
not like he should be giving him [__]
but I'm just saying if um he addresses
groaners put it that way is the best way
to put it but um so it was great working
with all those guys and um just had a
just had a great [__] night so
anyways so after the show Saturday night
um you know me Tom Papa and uh you know
Al
Madrigal we all go out to uh we all go
out to uh to dinner or something like
that right have a couple of drinks and
then we head back to the [__] W Hotel
or me and Tom did anyways cuz that's
where we where we were staying dude and
it was just an absolute [__] [__]
show that hotel I'm not saying is a bad
hotel but that hotel is for young
people it's not for 47-year-old [__]
freckled douchebag like me I I just
couldn't get over the level of shitfaced
this is coming from a drunk how [__]
hammered these people were first of all
I walked by the W Hotel at like
uh who the [__] was I with I was with
somebody I know the whole weekend kind
of Blended together but I swear to God
it was the afternoon and these [__]
these three like hot chicks come walking
out with with tattoos on their titties
like script writing they were [__]
[__] just walking right out I'm not
saying professionally but you know if
that's your daughter you're just you're
just talking to a wall for the rest of
your life being like I completely [__]
up script writing on your titties that I
mean I'm telling you right now if you
are a man and and a woman walks up to
you with script writing on her [__]
titties I'm telling you you run in the
other direction all right nothing good
is going to come from that interaction
okay and if there's any ladies listening
out there I challenge you to find a
wholesome woman who's going to be a good
mother with script writing on her
titties all right I'm sure you can find
one just like I can find a white guy
that can dunk a basketball there's
always [__]
exceptions all right but I'm just saying
generally speaking not even
generally 90% [__] speaking my
favorite's percentage 90% you just you
just run in the other [__] Direction
so anyways we come back from the
uh from the [__]
dinner and dude like this woman was so
okay outside this woman was so [__]
drunk like the kind of drunk you get
when you're in your 20s you don't know
how to stop right leather pants right
dressed like you know she's going to be
in a Rihanna video she's so drunk the
guy she's with is trying to hold her up
and she's got her head buried into him
like she's in like a Rugby scrum just
sort of trying to walk into him he's
going sweetheart sweetheart sweetheart
and we kind of was like Jesus Christ
what the [__] has all these you know
[__] tattooed titty HOSA walking out
of the W what's so funny is when you
check in the place during daylight hours
like it seems like a nice hotel but they
always had like the [__] club or du
Club da apostrophe whatever the young
kids say and somebody's up there
spinning right when the
[__] it it turns into an absolute
[__] [__] show and nobody can hold
their alcohol or or [__] did too many
drugs I don't know what it so anyways
this [__] this lady is like buried
her head into this guy and it's like
she's trying to like uh get a first down
and we looked away and then all of a
sudden you heard Boom the unmistakable
sound of a head hitting something solid
and she had fallen
down on her backside and and her
momentum carried her into the cab the
side of the cab that she was they were
trying to stick her into and she [__]
banged her head
um and then she got up um and was
laughing and I I I want to say it was
because she was a dumb [__] all right
now some you can say well why don't you
look at it like you know she's got a
sense of humor about herself like the
right to life people you know what she
was too pretty to have a sense of humor
about herself you know and that's
probably my you know issues with those
types of [__] women uh which of
course most of it is but yeah I would
just say no she just was like oh this is
funny cuz there's no consequences to
anything I did because as drunk as I am
I probably only paid for one [__]
drink this night you know what I mean oh
there's the stupid laptop let me know I
got a [__]
message
um so uh yeah I think she just was
enjoying the attention and her boyfriend
finally snapped and was like you shut
the [__] up get in the [__] cab and
she was still laughing you know what I
mean and I bet when it happens again
she'll laugh again because no one will
ever slap the [__] out of her because
she's a woman and it's against the rules
you know what I
mean so anyways so then me and [__]
um Tom walk into the uh not saying that
you should slap the [__] out of a woman
but you know there is something to be
gained every once in when you're truly
in the wrong and somebody just slaps you
in the [__] face and uh you know all
you have to deal with is the stinging
pain for like about 8 seconds there is
kind of a uh ah let me uh why don't I
think about uh some of my behavior over
the last couple of
minutes um another great advantage to
being a
guy also you can have a beard so you can
kind of cushion the The Sting of the
slap is he advocating domestic VI um
so then we go into the uh the W
Hotel um by the way what I just said
there is most bloggers [__] thought
process before they sit down to type um
anyways so we go into the [__] W
Hotel and we're standing there just like
weaving our way through unbelievably
[__] shitfaced
people um there doesn't seem to be any
sort of concern as to how these people
are getting home if they're driving it
is a city so I guess everybody was sort
of cabin it or ubering it I don't know
what the [__] they were doing so we're
weaving our way through these people we
get to the
[__] you get to the the elevators and
they got three elevators one of them
goes up to the top where the bar is it's
basically the [__] show elevator and
then the other two is for [__] old
people who just want to go to their room
and go to bed and of course the [__]
people keep getting on the wrong
elevators and all that type of stuff
right so as we're standing there all of
a
sudden this see a [__] guys walk in
wearing tuxedos and for some reason they
have these little stuffed animal ponies
with
them
um and they just all come filing in to
go to bed and I'm looking at Tom going
oh [__] these and they're [__] drunk
as hell and the guy shows up next to me
goes you want my pony this [__] guy
right these guys were like overthe Top
gay and they had like these Hitler Youth
haircuts it was really [__] bizarre
and they had Tuxedos and these stuffed
animal ponies or some [__]
um I don't know what was going on I have
no idea what the [__] was going on so we
skip an
elevator um and then wait for the next
one to come and by the time the next one
shows up there's another [__] herd of
uh Hitler Youth gay guys with ponies
trying to get in this as you have
scripted titty drunk girls trying to
figure out how to get up to the [__]
top of the place so they can get even
more shitfaced
um so anyways we get finally get on the
[__] elevator and
um you know
I a [__] hang on I got to take this I
got to hit pause here hold on hold on
hold
[Music]
on all right I'm back sorry about that
sorry about that I got some
[__] ah you know I had a relative
pass away so I got to go to the [__]
funeral sucks sucks I moved up and
everybody moves up you know somebody in
your family you know passes away
everybody moves up a spot everybody's
sad and everybody moves up a spot you
know what I mean who's next Who's Next
right [__] brutal anyways so let's
get back to the scripted titty whes all
right the scripted titty who is all
right and where where did I leave you
guys scripted titty [__] gay Hitler
Youth guys with ponies all dressed in
tuxedos like they just gave a piano
concerto or however the [__] you say so
I finally get all the way up to my room
and then I walk up and of course my key
doesn't [__] work or maybe I have a
key from the wrong Hotel cuz I'm always
on the [__] road I have no idea so I
got to go back downstairs get back on an
elevator that's actually empty and I go
downstairs doors open up more Hitler
Youth gay guys more scripted titty
[__] more [__] rugby scrums and uh
I get my key and I get back up there and
I was just
like H it's a [__] show I'm not saying
it's a bad Hotel you know what I mean
it's a [__] great Hotel tell if those
if that's what you're
into you know what I mean like stay
there during the week I think is fine if
you're an old man like me but on the
[__] weekends it is an absolute
[__] [__] show like it's was
literally it looked like a convention
for reality shows you know what I mean
uh stop writing script on your titties
you know on
VH1 um gay show Pony World War II P
piano
concerto for the for the straight guy
whatever the [__] you want to call it
um and uh you
know dumb [__] rugby chicks whatever the
[__] you want to call it but it was uh
it's a nightmare I'm done and you know
what's funny was during the day I was
already starting to get that feeling
like you know I I the second you know
you get into the W and they have like
that [__] that that option where you
can have like that neon aquarium
lighting around your [__] uh bed you
know cuz young people thinks that that
that like enhances their sexual
experience what they're really doing is
they're trying to cover for the fact
that they don't quite know what the [__]
they're doing you know what I
[Music]
mean or maybe it's part of the drug
thing I have no idea but I remember that
when I was younger and I was going to
hook up it was all about like the
lighting and having the right CD it was
all this extra [__] that you needed to
cover up for the fact that you didn't
quite know what the [__] you would doing
at least that was for me whatever I'm
just a grumpy old man don't listen to me
so anyways I [__]
uh so the food sucks at the W and it's
[__] like a zillion dollars so I'm
like all right I'm going to walk down
the street okay and I'm going to [__]
uh maybe find something so I I'm walking
down the street it's Saturday afternoon
and H Alabama is going to play uh the
Georgia Bulldogs between the hedges
right Georgia is favored because Alabama
lost to miss the [__] week before and
Georgia is actually given to two points
and in the back of my head I was like if
there was ever a [__] gift it would
be Alabama getting points but uh
fortunately I don't have access to a
[__] um a sports book so which is
good cuz that saves me a bunch of money
cuz anytime you're sitting there
thinking like oh my God this is a
[__] gift you end up losing so I
walked down the street like two blocks
not even a block and a half and I see
this Pub I'm like all right I'm going to
go in there turns out it's this [__]
insane Cigar Bar SL sports bar I pop in
there right there's this [__] guy
sitting there this Southern dude with
with the Georgia Bulldog logo on and
then there's like this old Jewish dude
sitting there old Jewish dudes are the
[__] best man they're the [__]
best give me ridiculous ridiculous
[__] life advice at the most
easygoing Pace ever are you
married are you in
love well that's good right they just
walk you all the way through [__]
life they're the best right so anyways
um so I'm sitting with that dude and
then there's the other guy you know and
they both got cigars going and uh I'm
thinking like well I'll [__] smoke
one later tonight I'm not going to smoke
during the day but I'm going to watch
the [__] game so they put the game on
the crowd's going nuts right [__]
Georgia Bulldogs are jumping up and down
Alabama comes out they get right in
their [__] face I'm getting amped up
like I'm going to play the game right
and it's a cigar bar so it's a chill
[__] Vibe you can hear the game
everything's great all of a sudden right
it literally is the [__] game's going
to
start this tabletop of five or six
people
walking with this [__] smug
jackass who just has a [__] opinion
on everything that he thinks is so
goddamn fascinating which is kind of
funny to hear me say but at least I know
I'm a [__] God knows I got an opinion
on everything but I know I'm a [__]
[__] and I also know that when you go
into a [__] Cigar Bar it's an old man
Vibe okay inside old man voices right
this [__] fat [__] I swear to God
remember that show Jake and the fat man
he looked like the fat man he sits down
and proceeds to start speaking as loud
as you could possibly [__] talk
without yelling and he keeps talking
about these he tells this [__] story
like three times about these cigarettes
he got in London that for some reason
are not legal in the United States he
and he kept going like it's
London but you cannot get them here I've
tried to order them but they are not
legal and it would always end it the
same way they are not legal and he'd go
why I don't know told that story three
times he only told it twice but I want
to say it felt like [__]
three and
uh is he's [__] screaming I finally
look over at the old Jewish to him like
if you like you believe this guy and the
old Jewish guy said something like you
know I feel this the same way like when
you get on the plane and there's a baby
crying next to you and I laughed I go
yeah but this guy should know better and
then the guy goes all right he goes and
he [__] he just got up and
left you know cuz he what he had on him
he had this beautiful [__] Cohiba and
he knew better he's like I'm not going
to [__] sit here and smoke this
unbelievable cigar with this fat [__]
screaming across the goddamn room right
that'd be like if you had like a great
glass of wine and the whole time you're
drinking it there was some guy yelling
in your [__] ear so he gets up and
leaves and I sat there and watched the
whole first quarter while simultaneously
trying to think of a nice way to ask
that guy politely to shut the [__] up
can somebody please help me with this
social moment because um I was literally
muttering over in the corner like I'd be
like and no matter how much I tried to
be nice like by the time I got to the
end of the sentence the rage would come
in and I would drop the f
bomb I'd be like excuse me sir you know
I'm not trying to be a jerk here but uh
you're sort of yelling and you know
you're in a [__] Cigar Bar you dumb
[__] no you can't do that can't do that
back it up um sir I'm not trying to
inhibit you from having a good time but
for some [__] reason you don't give a
[__] that you're doing that to me you
fat [__] right they I mean just kept
going like that right so I never ended
up saying anything and I finally
uh I don't know I I left after the first
quarter and I went back to the [__] W
Hotel and um by the way Jesus Christ
huh Alabama coming back answering the
Bell absolutely [__] kick the [__]
out the only the more they could have
done was rip the hedges out of the
[__] ground and uh God knows I was
rooting for Georgia I don't even I don't
even hate Alabama it's just you have to
root against them they're so [__]
good and uh you know what I forget the
guy's name who's that number two that
running back that Alabama has Jesus
Christ that guy's a [__] beast I
don't know the names I know number seven
on LSU is a monster this guy number two
like they're making these new kinds of
[__] running backs I don't get it
they're built like fullbacks but they
run as fast as running
backs and then they lower the shoulder
and they just absolutely destroy people
but
um unbelievable uh College
matchups this weekend but none of them
turned out to be the games like the the
back and forth that you thought they
were going to be
huh [__] Alabama kicks the [__] out
of Georgia and then Florida who was also
undefeated but was getting no respect
was playing Old Miss in the swamp and
everybody's thinking well Old Miss beat
Alabama right they're going to have
their way with Florida and Florida
absolutely kicked the [__] [__] out
of him I got to see that game too I
watched the replay last night and
um and then Notre Dame Clemson I was
rooting for Notre Dame because I'm going
to the Notre Dame USC game and I was
obviously hoping that Notre Dame would
win so they'd be undefeated and the game
would mean even more when they played
USC and as far as I can tell they got
handled cuz I haven't seen that game yet
um that game was going on while I was
doing the uh the Geraldo addiction
benefit and um but one of the stage
hands had the game going I just know it
was like 14 to three forever they kind
of went out early but um the only game
that was really [__] close and
exciting was probably a game nobody
thought was going to be which was uh
Ohio State versus Indiana which I ended
up turning on towards the ending cuz
Alabama was just Georgia just couldn't
answer the [__] Bell um so I ended up
putting that thing on and
um what a [__] game that was I love
how OSU kept think thinking they put
Alabama to bed you put him to sleep like
they had that one touchdown pass and the
guy does the old slit the [__] throat
thing like that's it nail in the coffin
which you know I felt it was too in
Indiana just kept coming back I didn't
know Indiana was that good they were
also undefeated so uh what I'm trying to
say is that when I wasn't weaving in and
out of script to titty [__] this
[__] weekend uh as I watched a lot of
goddamn
football I'll talk NFL here in a minute
let me uh let me get back to the uh got
to do a little bit of AD advertising
here sorry I have to hum my password I
forget oh Jesus Christ you got to put in
50 [__] goddamn things now and of
course it's wrong and of course it's
[__] wrong you know it's just my
[__] podcast why the [__] I mean my
laptop why the hell would I know how to
do it come on come
on bam there we go all right let's get
into the uh the reads let's get into
Bill Burr reading out loud oh Jes oh
Jesus all right NFL
football um I actually took an early
flight
out so I could get back in time to watch
the NFL football which I was able to do
by the way by the way when I was on the
plane I watched a guy in dress socks
they weren't gold toes they were
whatever I don't know if they were
compression socks I don't know what they
were but they were porno socks
dark colored socks and I watched this
guy walk into the the bathroom on the
airplane in
socks which in some weird way is
actually as
gross is [__] walking in with your
bare feet you know what I mean cuz
there's something about socks that
they're like
absorbent to take [__] urine and feal
matter and have them up against your
feet for the rest of your [__] FL
what the [__] what kind of a [__]
animal I just want to say to the guy
like dude do you realize you just walked
into a public bathroom and your
socks are you out of your [__]
mind at the very least there's like 20
people's [__]
urine in your socks up against your
[__]
skin animals and then I'm also thinking
like you know maybe this guy is
preparing for when the dollar col CES or
whatever and you just got to start
eating squirrels and everything and and
maybe maybe your
neighbor and as I'm sitting there puking
you know like Henry Hill when they dig
up [__] Billy bats and I can't handle
it you know and he's just he's ready for
he didn't give a [__] he walked into a
public bathroom and his [__] stalking
feet absolute [__] animal and had
this really nice male stewardess on
there but every time he went to talk to
me he put his hand on my shoulder take
your hand off my
shoulder may
steis you creeping me
out I can hear your voice
Stanley I don't know why I think his
name is Stanley it's an old person name
um I need to make a human connection
would you like some more
peanuts um so anyways I landed in time
um I only missed the first half of the
first game and I went in and I I watched
the Giant versus the
bills this makes no sense because I am a
Patriots fan but I [__] love the
Giants I love the Giants they always got
a great [__] defense you see that
Maniac they got on defense the guy's
510 10 guy's 541 I'm so impressed my
voice is cracking guys 5' 10 playing on
the defensive line plowed through two
guys and got a [__] sack guys a
[__]
animal you're literally watching Rudy
and you know what's funny unlike the
movie Rudy with the dude playing him
looked like an absolute [__] who
shouldn't even be playing [__]
volleyball this guy looked like a
[__] animal it's like he was 510 but
was built like he was [__]
6'4 um you know they got Odell Beckham
you see that catch the guy made it
didn't even count was so [__]
unbelievable it still made the highlight
real and
um I don't know I was watching what Rex
could do against a team like that plus
you know Rex in our division and uh I
know that we're going to be playing the
Giants I don't know how the [__] we're
ever going to beat him we never beat him
they beat us in exhibition they beat us
in the playoffs they beat us in the
regular season I I don't think we've
ever beat the Giants during the Tom
Coughlin Eli
Manning um era I wonder when the last
time we beat we beat him was I'm sure
some [__] nerd will go out there and
let me know or tell me that I'm wrong oh
actually in [__] all right any
significant game they always kick our
[__] ass so um but I I always love
defensive-minded teams
um so even though they beat us I mean
what am I going to get mad cuz they
always beat us that's on us right figure
out how to [__] beat him so anyway so
and I also love watching Rex lose it's
fun you know and uh if I can watch him
lose while he wears a pink hat and
headsets I mean that's even better so uh
I watched that uh still Buffalo looked
pretty good man and I think their uh
their quarterback there what is it
Travis trit the Black version of that
name
uh I don't
know Trayvon third Guild I don't know
what his [__] name is sadale three um
he looked [__] great he look great
but he looked way better than when we
were playing him when he was throwing it
like 90 miles over everybody's head
looked like he settled down and
everything so I got to watch the Bills
lose and then I watched the Packers
um actually play a surprisingly tough
game against the 49ers I thought that
they were going to crush him but uh as
much as the score looked like it was uh
a one-sided Affair listen to me using
all the sports cliches um I thought
49ers played really tough and uh then I
watched the [__] Saints game uh
Cowboys game and I had that game [__]
recorded what a goddamn game watched it
all the way to the end and the one time
I don't add the extension right as
they're lining up to take the field goal
to tie it up
um my [__] uh my my recorder cut out
so then I had to go on TV and I was just
saying all right it's a 30 yard you know
they hit the [__] thing and it turns
out they missed it evidently they missed
it cuz some guy with a giant white belly
what I looked like a few months ago
lifted his shirt up and [__]
distracted him and uh but Saints still
ended up winning the [__] game but
[Music]
um I don't know you know I just realized
I don't know anybody's name I can sit
there and I can watch the whole [__]
game I don't know anybody's game who's
the Cowboys backup he's one of those
unfortunate guys who's a quarterback you
know who does not not look good when he
wearing a when he was wearing a helmet
he's got those baby fat cheeks you know
so it all mushes in together looks like
Stan humph you know what I mean that's
just so unfortunate because you know if
you're going to stand back there and
have 6'4 6'5 in guys who run 440s coming
into [__] lay out you can at least be
getting a ridiculous amount of ass right
you know what I
mean you can have you know you can have
a cute little face like old Tony Romo
there you know as he sitting there
wearing the Tom Landry Hat he's got his
arm in his sling that's all women give a
[__] about in Dallas oh I just want to
rub his
shoulder what did he break um was it his
collar
bone white
gold um anyways whatever that guy's name
is I thought when the saints went ahead
I was like ah they don't have it in them
this guy's a game manager they don't
have it in them to come back and score
and lo and behold they went right down
the [__] field and they scored and it
was great to see Tony Romo really being
happy for his backup right he knows he
knows he still has the job he knows he's
better he knows he looks better in a
[__] helmet he's going to sell more
merch right I don't think I would look
any worse in a football helmet and a
closeup on HDTV than that poor son of a
[__] that's playing for the Cowboys but
God damn it he got the job done drove
him right down the [__] field right
threw it to that tight end that's been
there forever JJ Whitten JJ Stokes
whatever the [__] his name is I don't
know anybody's name anymore I don't play
Fantasy Football all right I'm a man I'm
over
40 I'm actually thinking about starting
to play Fantasy Football just so I can
[__] learn the the players names
again I
actually I'm embarrassed to say that I
went on the uh on the internet to see
you know look at some of the stats of
like the top receivers and I didn't know
anybody's name I didn't know anybody's
name as far as running backs went I know
Marshon
Lynch I know Ray
Rice
and I think that's it I don't know
anybody
else I I kept hearing names from the SEC
going didn't that guy play for
Arkansas didn't that guy win the Heisman
Trophy Darren mcfat didn't he win the
Heisman Trophy in 2009 I think he was on
the Saints and then the [__]
uh the guy from Arkansas was on uh the
Cowboys I I don't I don't [__]
anything
anymore I don't know what happened to me
I what happened to my [__] life there
I used to know all of this sh you know
why I used to collect football cards
that's what that's what it was that's
what it was um anyways but it was a
great whole [__] uh a great uh
weekend of watching football and then as
always I tell you what I do is I taped
uh a 1:00 game and I
taped an extra 1:00 and an extra 4:00
game and I also still have the the Notre
Dame game to watch so tonight is Monday
Night Football I can watch that Tuesday
night I can watch the one 1:00 game I I
don't give a [__] that I know what
happens it's still fun to watch
Wednesday Wednesday I can watch the 4:00
game Thursday you got Thursday football
Friday I'll watch the Notre game Dame
game and then Saturday it starts all
over again there you
go and if you want the woman in your
life or the man in your life whatever
your deal is to feel underappreciated
you will record football games the way I
do then you sit there the whole [__]
week watch like your some coach watch
game tape I got to I got to learn the
names guys I apologize I apologize to
anybody uh who had a great [__] game
I should at least know your goddamn name
right Drew Brees I know Drew
Brees I know Aaron
roders I can't even remember the name of
the [__] quarterback from uh
Seattle or the quarterback what the
[__] Richard
Sherman colie
Kaepernick who's the guy who's trying to
be like The Waltons with 52 kids there
for for uh San Diego Phillip rivis I
know
him Andrew luck I guess quarterbacks you
know or I know I don't [__] what the
[__] I know there's some guy in Atlanta
who's
unbelievable an unbelievable receiver
Odell Beckham I know Bill why don't you
learn the [__] names instead of
torturing all right all right
sorry my my mistake Oh Hey listen I got
to give a uh
I got to give a
um a shout out here to uh when I when I
was in DC now that I [__] all over the W
Hotel which is a great hotel if you're
in your 20s okay and you got scripted
titties or your uh gay guy with a Hitler
Youth [__] haircut and a little show
Pony you know what I mean are you some
[__] uh Hottie with leather pants
who's into rugby when you're drunk um I
got to give a shout out here uh one of
the great things that I I found when I
was in DC
this is for everybody out there anybody
who plays professionally or uh just is
like a drum nerd like me I found a great
place for 15 bucks an hour that you can
go play drums at uh it's called seven
lessons
drums in
um in Washington DC I I showed up there
um I play for two hours on Friday and
two hours on Saturday I could not have
had a better time I went to two
different drum rooms the drums were
top-notched they were tuned up they
sounded great and
um I mean that's to me when I'm on the
road you know and uh that's one of the
greatest days of my life if I can be on
the road and I can just for two hours
during the day you know to combat the
[__] loneliness and all the [__]
that goes on when you're out there just
sitting there you know sitting there on
a Thursday when there's nothing on TV
Dude an ESPN at 2:00 in the [__]
afternoon is one of the funniest things
you're ever going to watch like did you
see that former jet making fun of Tom
Brady was hilarious he gave it up he
said he's arguably the greatest
quarterback of all time but he's a nerd
what do he keep call kept saying corny
the guy's corny how many air high fives
is this guy going to miss just trashing
him was [__] hilarious I would think
if Tom Brady heard it he would laugh and
then they went back to skip bis and you
would have thought somebody spit on the
[__] uh World Trade Memorial he's
like his comments
were this
able I would guess that they're
possibly born in jealousy is people know
I am a huge fan of Tom Brady I don't I
don't agree with those comments it's
just like dude are you [__] serious
right now and what it is is it's 2: in
the afternoon they've already shown you
the highlights nothing new has happened
and they just got to try and milk it for
all it's worth so there's nothing worth
to do um people uh you know if you're a
fan of this podcast if you go go to my
website and you see the cities that I'm
going to be in if you guys know cool
Studio places where I could just sit
down and chill out and [__] play
drums for a couple hours uh by all means
let me know if you run one let me know
I'll give it a shout out on the podcast
it
is it it's my favorite thing to do when
I go on the road if I can actually find
a place like that and I found a great
one I know there's a lot of comics out
there that play drums you know you bring
your iPhone you plug it in you pretend
you're [__] John bonam for hours how
much fun is that uh seven lessons drums
in uh Washington DC if you guys know
some other places give me the heads up
because um I got to be honest with you
it's frustrating you
know to learn some [__] and then go on
the road for a week and you come back
and you [__] you know one step
forward two steps back it's a great
[__] way I feel like I got four hours
better or at least maintained it so uh
thank you to everybody over there seven
lessons drums all right before I get
into the questions unfortunately you
guys got to listen to me read out loud
again here uh that is
correct I got my Atomic
holds and um I got a buddy coming in
who's going to do everything the right
way because uh even though I have a stud
finder and I got a drill I do not trust
myself to put as a standup comic to put
this thing up correctly and not uh do
unbelievable damage to myself you know I
don't be hanging by all my body weight
swinging from one hole to another you
know it's my Pasty legs are out in front
of me and then that thing [__] gives
way you know I'm at that [__] age
where then I'll have that pain for the
rest of my [__] life I I'll finally
know what it's like to be sacked in the
NFL to [__] be horizontal 4 feet off
the ground and land land on concrete
right feel like that's what AstroTurf
feels like all right let's get to the
questions
um by the way if you want to
uh you know what I don't even have the
email what is the [__] email God damn
it Bill atth MMP podcast.com that's
where you send all your uh emails to um
if you guys know a better way to [__]
learn the players names nowadays other
than playing that fantasy stuff I guess
I just have to keep going to the website
um all
right Boston hey Bill me and my wife are
headed to Boston for the first time any
tips on the best places to eat I hate
when people do this to me cuz I moved
away from there in
1995 so half the [__] I'm going to tell
you to go to is probably not even there
anymore uh how about things we shouldn't
Miss I'm going to Fenway for sure but
after that we are clueless any help
would be appreciated thanks and love uh
the podcast except for the disparaging
remarks about
Sacramento ha [__] ha come on dude
you know Sacramento Sacramento is a
weird place you know what I mean it's
either totally Shady or you feel like
you're in a Donnie Osman [__]
Christmas
special got to be honest with you I
don't know much about Sacramento to be
totally honest with you cuz every time I
stayed there I I didn't have a car and I
was working the uh the punch line there
and I stayed at the comedy condo across
the street and then they had a dirty
McDonald's that I would go
to
um so that's what it's based on other
than the fact one time I went to a
Sacramento Kings game and I went to the
downtown area and I felt like I was in
Utah in the whitest Mormon sense of the
word um which doesn't mean it's bad I
mean I'm white
I don't know when it's so white that I'm
uncomfortable though you know what I
mean I don't know I probably don't know
[__] I will tell you this have I've been
telling you that I've been watching The
Ultimate Fighter with Conor McGregor
Conor McGregor and uh and
um ah
[__] what an [__] I was just going to
give him props of how [__] funny he's
been Uriah Faber Jesus Christ I got to
stop talking on cell phones dude that
guy has been [__] I knew Conor
McGregor was going to be funny that's
why I was tuning in to watch but who
knew how how [__] funny UAH was
haven't I already talked about this when
McGregor was talking [__] to him about
what the [__] he would do to him and
then he just looks at him he goes he
goes Connor do I strike you as a fearful
man and he keeps making fun of Connor's
big [__] head which I don't even
think he has a big head but I think it's
starting to [__] with them um anyways
it's funny man it's it's it's you know
it's a great goddamn show and it's fun
watching two guys talking [__] knowing
that neither one of them is full of [__]
knowing that both of them know how to
fight you know what I mean so many times
when you sit there you're watching guys
talking [__] I'll [__] do this I'll
do this hey you don't want to [__] with
me it's usually people bluffing like me
you know what I mean or my good friend
Joe de Roa i' never seen a guy who knew
how to fight Less Talk More [__] and
bars but he just did it with Supreme
confidence as he was backing up and the
person would never take in that
information he'd always kind of Psych
him out Joe's got this way of scrunching
up his [__] eyebrows and making this
face even though he he's got glasses on
you know and he looks like he works at a
library you you can think well maybe
this guy knows some [__] maybe this
guy's [__] crazy so anyway so it's
great to watch them talking [__] um just
professional fighters anyways it's not
even like they're not talking [__]
they're not talking [__] they can do
everything that they're saying
um anyways speaking of that when's the
next UFC thing I got I'm I'm jonesing
for one I think I missed the last one
cuz I was on the road so uh all right
whatever I'm babling here let's get to
the questions all right this guy's
asking me what's a good thing to do here
in Boston uh well let's see I used to
love going to Dominics to get a slice of
pizza that does not exist
anymore um you know what's there now A W
Hotel I'll tell you what to see scripted
titties go to uh the W Hotel uh right
there on [__] warron Street on the
corner warron street used to be a
parking lot do I even know anything
anymore combat zone is all [__]
hotels I just know touristy
[__] oh my God this is
terrible the Swan Boats I don't know
anything about my city
anymore I know that if you go to Fenway
they bought up like the rounding block
and you can't go down
there you know what sir you've stumped
me I'd say go to Harvard Square and go
to the tasty get yourself a burger that
doesn't exist
anymore oh my God this is see this is
what's so [__] sad man this is what's
sad this is why they say you can never
go home again cuz you move away and you
come back everybody moved away or
[__] died and everything closed up
and is now a [__]
Arby
um you know what Siri you stump me I
have no [__]
idea I have no idea definitely take in a
sporting event um fortunately with the
internet I'm sure you can get some ideas
and hey dude if you learn anything if
you go to some place cool why don't why
don't you let me know here's a touristy
place you can go to is the um the the
Union Oyster House that's like you know
like [__] Paul River went in there
and had a [__] Sam Adams back in the
day and by that I mean he had a gay
relationship with him cuz the beer did
not exist um that's a real touristy spot
I'm sure that's everybody's rolling
their eyes right now like oh my god dude
don't [__] send them there um tell
you what I'll retweet places if people
know some good places
um other than that I just know go to the
cowon that's why I used to do standup
they got some good Chinese food I got
nothing go to the New England
Aquarium go look at the sad fish that
want to be back in the ocean oh I know
the North End go to the [__] North
End go right down what is it Handover
Street I don't remember the name of the
street begins with an H go down that
[__] Street and uh you
know find somebody who looks really
Italian from the old neighborhood and be
like listen I don't want to eat on this
street what's one a couple of blocks
over that you go to I swear to God I
won't tell anybody and it'll be the best
[__] Italian that you can get in uh
in Boston at least I think so oh God
that's sad that really made me feel
[__] old oh here's another here
another one uh Black Mass hey Billy
Bulger nice nice [__] call back there
not call back nice reference there Billy
Bulger he was the politician did you see
black mass he said I'm usually a pretty
easy critic but it was pretty rough
nothing really happens and what does
happen has been refuted by everyone who
knows the story well you can say that
about every [__] movie I don't mean
things like getting the color of his
shirt right but major events and motives
really disappointing well you know you
can kind of say that about uh Good
Fellas the way you know me and verie
were talking about that how they made
Henry Hill look like ryota this is
greatl looking movie star and then when
you see him he was a little [__]
worm um so you know it is a movie I
haven't seen it um um I know some
people liked it some people didn't but I
that I'm still going to go see it cuz I
love Johnny Depp and also I remember
when No Country for Old Men came out
everybody was go what was with the
ending the movie sucked and it ended up
being like my favorite one ever so I did
not see it and um I don't go to see
movies to get a history lesson and I
don't think you should I think you go
there to be
entertained um I don't know it looks
[__] great to me so I'm definitely
going to go see it I think that's one of
those ones that everybody thought it was
going to be a big shoot them up kind of
thing and they did it in a little bit of
a different way so they're like what the
[__] and I'm calling it right now when
it [__] goes on Netflix everything be
like you know what I actually liked it
FY liked it you know so
um I can't tell you this though that is
a scary guy that you did not want to
[__] with that's all I knew when I was
living in Massachusetts and fortunately
I lived out in the safe suburbs and
played street hockey in a culdesac so I
didn't have any sort of southy Goodwill
Hunting upbringing
whatsoever uh you know we just drove
around in [__] cars with a case of beer
in the weekends drove around trying to
find other kids driving around and
[__] with cases of beer you know
that's that's what you did that was the
excitement in my town um and you know
what we knew enough to stay away from
heroin it's [__] killing me now
seeing all these kids on heroin after
they get on the painkillers it's
unfuckingbelievable
man it's
unfuckingbelievable you know what I mean
every day you you still want to [__]
do it again I mean that's what a thing
to do to yourself I don't think that
that's worth it you know to put it
through the biggest understatement ever
major [__] problem though it's major
it's a [__] problem Massachusetts
problem in Vermont Maine all these
places I'm going to that were like the
kind of places you used to go to to get
away from that
[__]
um it's out in the suburbs man it's a
[__] epidemic anyways all right wife
thinks I'm nuts hey Billy Da Vinci my
wife thinks I'm losing my mind well join
the club couple weeks back I told her
that I at the ripe age of 49 want to
learn how to paint dude that's [__]
great that's [__] dude you this is
the thing man if you want to stay
excited in life and if you want to fend
off depression like this is a really
depressing week for me man my uncle
passed away and uh he's just the
greatest guy ever and um
there's that thing you know knowing I'm
never going to see him again and then
that other thing as far as like like
that level of my relatives one of them
passed away like he's the first one and
like I'm the next wave and you just
start doing the math in your head and
how quick the last decade went by and
it's like oh my God I'm going to [__]
be that guy in like two months you feel
so what's you can't stop the
clock from ticking but you know nobody
can stop you from enjoying yourself or
having a good time unless you let them
so
um you know I think that's how I ended
up you know I
just I don't know I I am a big [__]
believer in learning how to do [__] and
that whole hey Jack of all trades master
and none go [__] yourself I do standup
all right I do that thing I'm never
going to master it cuz the second I
think that I've mastered it I'm going to
stop growing and then the depression
comes back like for me when I'm standing
still and I got time to think and
contemplate like however I'm wired it
just it puts me in a [__] Funk so I'm
always chasing that next [__] carrot
thing like I'm learning how to smoke
meat you know I was going to try to uh
smoke some ribs this week but I got to
go to the funeral I'm
hoping you know I can maybe give that a
shot this weekend but but
um you know playing drums I learned how
to fly a
helicopter um I got into old cars and
stuff you know and I have like you know
I don't have a tremendous amount of
knowledge in any of that [__] but other
than obviously I got my pilot's license
I had to know what the [__] I was I kind
of know how to do this um I'm doing oh
by the way I'm doing a flight this week
where uh I'm going to land at uh El
Monte um and then I'm going to do a lap
around the Rose Bowl which is so [__]
cool I'm starting to like my big thing
right now before I get instrument
trained is I really want to get
comfortable on the radio and uh um in um
you know I already did the advanced auto
rotation class so I know I can get that
thing to the ground if the [__]
engine cuts out um which was the big
thing for me so now I'm past that fear
that I know if something bad happens I
know I can get to the ground and I have
[__] confidence in that so now my
next little hurdle is I gotta get
comfortable on the radio
you know uh know what to say and just
get better at listening and looking for
traffic and all that type of [__] the
only way to do it is to go [__] do it
so getting back to what you're talking
about is you want to learn how to paint
at the ripe age of 49 like I just love
even the way you're writing that I mean
I don't want to put words into your
mouth but the the tone underneath that
is that you shouldn't be trying new
things or learning new things at 49 you
should be set in your ways you should
have your [__] routine and for some
people that is comforting but uh dude
[__] that if you want to learn how to
paint I don't give a [__] of you're
89 it'll keep your mind active as
opposed to sitting there rotten in
between your ears so anyways he said you
know I'm rip old age of 49 and I let her
know that I want want to paint she
immediately changed the subject to
shed uh
that oh she immediately changed the
subject to to the shed okay that needs
cleaning out I explained to her that one
has nothing to do with the other I can
clean the shed and learn how to PL paint
I'm
self-employed I brought it up again and
she rolled her eyes I love my wife but
this has me wondering uh what other
things has she shot down in the past
that maybe I just accepted uh you talk
about you talked about that in your last
special special what's my move here I
don't want to pass over this I'd rather
address it and fix it uh what your next
move uh to go down to the art supply
store and get yourself a [__] eel and
some paint and I would learn how to
paint this is okay this is the deal dude
she has no [__] argument here this is
like literally you want to learn to do
something that's going to make your life
more
enjoyable um and that's what I would say
I would just say listen I want to learn
something that's going to uh make my
life more enjoyable and fill me with
happiness
and uh doesn't involve me uh [__]
another woman so what exactly is your
problem lady right what is your
problem um if you want to address it
like dude you're going to destroy in
this just sit down and just say listen
uh I need to talk to you about something
all right all right immediately she's
going to be off guard because she didn't
because you know there's going to be a
talk and you've had a time to [__]
get your ideas in order and just say
listen um the other day when I mentioned
to you that I wanted to learn how to
paint you immediately said that the shed
needed to be cleaned out when I told you
that I had enough time to do both you
rolled your eyes at me and uh don't say
it the way I just said you rolled your
eyes see I get the anger you got you
rolled your eyes you go back you bring
your head back so you're not getting in
a grill so she can actually hear you and
she won't be on the defensive just be
like look you rolled your eyes at me and
um
that hurt my feelings because if there
was something that you ever wanted to do
that was going to make you happy I would
never come at you in a negative way I
would encourage you to do it so I was
just wondering what was behind
that and uh you know just let her talk
and talk your way through and just say
listen like for the rest of my life I'm
going to be trying new things because it
makes my life enjoyable and it would
crush me that the woman that I love
would somehow get in the way of that all
right the shed's going to be cleaned out
and I'm going to learn how to paint all
right and I don't want to paint a
picture of you being a [__] to me so why
don't you lighten up there sugar tits
see right there see what happens always
in the end I get mean that's why I
couldn't talk to that guy in the [__]
uh Cigar
Bar um all
right okay Bill aren't you paranoid hey
Billy B uh aren't you a bit paranoid
with all this tracking and surveillance
uh I think he's talking about the
microchipping and all that [__] he said
I noticed that this is a typical
American psyche oh Jesus Christ here in
Europe we are a bit well a lot more
relaxed about those things
um I don't know if people are doing this
just to try to get me all [__] [__]
up but I noticed that about people from
other countries like they are so [__]
arrogant with like they they think they
know oh the American psyche like what do
you know about the American psyche you
don't [__] live here what the [__]
you watch on the BB
BC you [__] dope over in America
we're a little more relaxed really based
on
what based on what isn't that where the
last two world wars started oh what are
you going way back to then look what
happened when with [__] Russia pulled
out all those the Bosnian serbs Russia
you're not more
relaxed you're not any more [__]
relaxed [__] maniacs you can't even
go to a football game with without
beating the [__] out of each other
getting all [__] hammered you're not
more
relaxed all right I don't see that at
all I'm not saying we're better than you
or what like you know and also you're
not a bit more paranoid I love how
Scotland shot down Monsanto when they
wanted to have their [__] genetically
altered food coming to their country and
they're like you're not [__] doing
that I don't think you're more relaxed I
don't think Greece looks that [__]
relaxed right now as they got in bed
with the evil [__] bankers and now I
don't know what the [__] happened over
there their whole [__] economy
collapsed I don't see many relaxed
things over there yeah nice and relaxed
you draw a cartoon and then somebody
comes in and sprays the place with
bullets oh yeah it's so [__] chill
God it's so refined and relaxed over
there [__] neo-nazis can't even go to
a [__] football game without being
reminded of
Hitler Jesus [__] Christ what because
you got a king and a queen riding around
in a carriage you think it's all [__]
chill
um
anyways my question here is why I see
that you will reject anything that makes
your life easier and more convenient um
well it all depends on how you uh Define
convenient which is spelled
incorrectly he goes but it's collecting
any data whether it's purchasing habits
location and such I prefer to see
personalized ads rather than random ads
for moms if I buy something all the the
time in a market why not create Club
card you will pay less oh my God what a
dope it doesn't matter that you will
receive an email every once in a while
which will land in spam anyways dude
you're not paying
less do you want to understand you're
not paying less do you know anything
about
corporations they're never going to make
less money they're going to create this
whole thing like hey join the club man
and look you'll get 40% off this [__]
that we can't [__] sell that's what
they give you a a a discount on and then
if they actually got some whatever their
prime rib is that they're selling you
all they do is Jack up the price go hey
it used to be this and now it's this so
you you give the P the
perception that you're getting a lower
price and I don't have I'm not paranoid
dude I am informed believe it or not now
I always call myself a [__] dope all
right cuz I know that I am and I don't
think that I know everything but um I do
understand how corporations
operate okay and they literally sit
there and they go dead babies or more
money for us and they actually debate
going like well how much will the
parents suing us for their dead babies
cost us to settle out of court versus
how much money you know to have these
lead infused [__] pacifiers and if
the pacifiers I mean using this
obviously is a [__] I know you're
rolling your eyes cuz you [__] think
you know everything which you certainly
do as you're [__] on my country a
country you don't even [__] live in
um they will choose the [__] the
product auto companies did
that you know where where they knew like
[__] police like with the Crown
Victoria when they knew cops were
getting rear ended when they on the road
and were burning to death they [__]
squelched all of that [__]
information and they took the the
[__]
lawsuit all right they're not on your
side they're not trying to make your
life any easier what they're trying to
do is they're G they're they're they're
invading your [__] privacy like look
dude I don't have a problem that you
don't have a problem with somebody
invading your privacy okay but you
should have to give consent to that and
what I don't like is I have not given my
consent okay I didn't give my consent
for you to put my [__] bank account
information
online they just [__] did it I don't
want a bank online and they just put it
up there anyways then I had to go down
to the [__] bank and go through this
whole [__] Maze and they were very
hostile before they would let me take my
own banking information off of the
[__] internet that they exposed my
entire [__] adult life of working to
getting hacked into they exposed all of
that they made the choice and not me I
think that that's [__] up and if you
think like when you go through
history how human beings have handled
any level of power I'm talking about the
average person just getting their own
[__] sitcom what that does to their
[__] psyche
okay when you're trying to take over
[__] the thought of rebellion and all
that is always in the back of your head
if you [__] microchip everybody and
you know where everybody is you can
[__] just and and you put all the
money is then on the microchip and all
your [__] is just on that all you got to
do is just shut somebody's chip off and
you've killed any sort of rebuttal to
anything that you're doing that's it in
the future when you go to a protest
they'll just [__] they'll just have
they'll have some sort of satellite
everybody's chip number will show up and
they'll just shut it off and they'll
starve you for [__] 10 days so you
learn the [__] lesson they won't kill
you cuz if they kill you that'll that'll
cause more people to get upset they just
sort of kick your back and then people
like yeah you know what I'd love to go
to a [__]
protest you know right now it's like I'd
love to go to a protest but the cops are
going to beat the [__] out of me which
is so [__]
ridiculous you can't go to a protest
there is no protesting you go to a
protest and the cops beat the [__] out
of you that's basically what happens
then they always try to act like oh well
these guys got out of line give me a
[__] break they've been doing that
since the [__] beginning um so I
don't think I'm paranoid sir if you want
all of your [__] information and all
that out there to make your life more
convenient and you don't have to think
you have to think less like I don't I
don't think that's good I don't think
that having like that [__] app on my
phone this is my own personal thing and
I'm going to [__] on your [__]
country I only [__] on you after you
[__] on my country all
right okay I don't think there's
anything wrong with your continent or
your country and I don't think there's
anything [__] wrong with the fact
that you don't give a [__] about this if
you think it makes your life easy that's
fine all
right but I mean I I'm not I I don't
want to be microchipped dude I don't I
also find that on my phone the the
little GPS thing that [__] tell make
a left and blah blah blah blah blah I've
never had more [__] problems getting
to when I had the map and I had to use
my brain I was way more
effective way more
effective I start [__] looking at the
picture they'll go make a right and then
there's like a lazy right and a right
and I'm looking at it and I can't you
know as I'm [__] driving it makes me
more dangerous a driver I I don't I
don't know I like using my [__] brain
I'll figure out my own [__]
um and I don't think that this stuff
makes my life easier because it's
constantly has to be updated and
replaced and then you replace it and
then you throw it in the [__] ocean
and you're polluting the environment
that you're in you know and I know a guy
like you is probably rolling your
[__] eyes right now because all you
give a [__] about is your little flat or
whatever the [__] you live and having
them oh yeah I like soft t-shirts oh
thank you for that ad right there that I
can click on like if that's how you want
to live your life God bless you but uh I
don't think I'm being
paranoid at all
you know what I mean anyways he said I'd
love to see in Poland maybe the next
time you are in Europe uh I would love
to go to Poland I actually heard that uh
up along the coast is beautiful and
actually the south of Poland is great
places to take vacation who [__] knew
I didn't know that till I went over
there so my apologies to any other part
of Europe I just I'm just so sick of
people like uh not seeing how [__] up
their place is and just constantly
uh you know I remember one time I was
flying across the country there was this
chick from Australia
we're literally in the United States
flying from one US city to another and
she's [__] on the US to me a US
citizen I'm not saying we don't have our
faults absolutely Absol [__] lutely
you know what I mean I don't know what
the [__] we're doing we won a World War
in four and a half years we spent 15
[__] years 14 years over in [__]
Iraq I don't know what we're
doing trying to put up
Starbucks
um anyways I'm not saying we don't have
our [__] faults but I mean just this
is just a common level of
decency you know what I mean like I to
sit there and go to another country and
[__] on the country to somebody from
that country and then say what country
you're from I don't know there there's a
[__] level of ignorance there that uh
I just feel like Americans are always
getting accused of and everybody else is
patting themselves on the back about how
[__] amazing their country is because
it's not the US and I'm just saying you
know you guys got your [__] warts too
all
right so [__] relax I like going to
your countries I like meeting the people
over there and I know I tease you I make
fun of your sports and blah blah blah
blah blah I know I compared Sydney
Australia to Sacramento California but
you know I being you know just busting
you [__] balls maybe I'm being overly
sensitive maybe I'm the cut this I have
no
idea all I know is uh I got to get on
with my [__] day here cuz uh
obviously I got the [__] I have to
deal with you know [__] annoyed this
[__] out of me I got to say this really
[__] quickly cuz I don't think it's
going to get a laugh from The Comedy
Club cuz when I was watching CNN and
that [__] horrific shooting at the
school happened and this [__] lady
all right she looks like Mary Lou Ren is
flipping out cuz she can't get the the
the the right number of dead people at
the school it's like isn't it enough
that it's a [__] tragedy what are you
flipping like the sheriff on there
[__] nine people or 10 people it's
like lady [__]
relax the tragedy happened the tragedy
is going to exist tomorrow all right
maybe law enforcement is trying to
figure out who [__] did it why and
all of that [__] stop acting like you're
solving the [__] case you're freaking
out cuz you want to get the right amount
of dead people so you have the accurate
[__] so people will go to you when
there's a [__] tragedy so you can
sell get make more money when you sell
your [__] Froot Loops your
[__] you [__] oh it [__] annoyed
me she's sitting there screaming and
yelling says sweetheart just go to
bed all right just go to bed I don't
need to see and I and I don't understand
people who sit there and they watch that
[__] and then they show the pictures of
of the uh the relatives and the friends
crying hugging and all that every time I
saw it I would turn the [__] Channel
I don't want to see what the guy looked
like who did it I don't want to know his
[__] name [__] that piece of [__] I
don't know if he's alive or dead if you
know if he's alive uh they should kill
him they should be this is the guy this
is the guy who did it without a doubt we
know this okay you just take him right
out in the [__] Street two behind the
air that's it over I think they should
do that with all sex offenders all
pedophiles all of that you can't cure
those people just take them right out
two by the [__] ear
right drag him off throw him in a pit
bulldoze over him and then uh I don't
know [__] turn the music
on all right that's the podcast for this
week everybody well got a little
sideways there in the end got a little
side I look obviously I'm a little
[__] parent I'll give you that but I
think it's a healthy [__] paranoia
you know what I mean you know when
you're watching cigarette companies
going like I don't think cigarettes are
uh I don't think they're addictive at
all ignoring all of their [__]
information right government spraying
agent orange over its own [__] troops
ignoring it denying it
right what's the latest one oh that
fracking that [__] absolutely
destroys the drinking water and then
those Corporation guys sit there going
like I would drink that drinking water
well here's some would you like to drink
it no I don't think I'm [__] paranoid
I don't want those types of people to go
around having more information on the
public because they're absolute [__]
Psychopaths dude the head of nestle
doesn't think water is a basic human
right he wants to he wants to own the
rain these people are out of their
[__] minds and the president only
makes 400 Grand a [__] year and needs
that guy's money so they're not going to
talk about those guys oh but God forbid
God forbid you make fun
[Music]
of what's up everybody and welcome back
to the anything better podcast NFL
Edition going into week number five uh
before we get started we want to shout
out our great sponsor bet MGM guys use
the BET MGM app uh use our code bur 200
put in as little as uh a $10 deposit in
and they will give you 200 $ in wages
regardless of the outcome of your bet
it's a great deal all you have to do is
go to bet MGM app download the app use
our code bur to uh 200 and uh that's it
put $10 in and bet responsibly they also
have a Survivor pool where you could go
in and you pick a team to win and as
long as that team wins not even against
the spread just wins that week you
continue to uh to move on and you get
prizes at the end um it's good week for
Bill bad week for me I went down went
back down I went back down to four under
I'm six and 10 because I went U one and
three but I'll tell you I just had bad
picks other than Jacksonville nothing
was close all the teams I picked were
wrong the Saints are not who I thought
they were bill you had a great week
dude yeah that uh you know Bill's
Dolphins kind of played out the way I
thought it was gonna uh I can't remember
who I took all I remember was the
[__] Steelers didn't show up did they
oh my God they got I guess the Texans
have a good defense it's no secret
anymore Paul and I'll be yelling a
little bit because I can't [__] hear
anything you know why Paul because the
latest download makes you have to buy
the new [__] phone and the government
doesn't do anything about it the fact
that this company is sabotaging their
own [__] product forcing me to
[__] buy another one [__] Steve
Jobs you know not even [__] Steve Jobs
[__] these [__] [__] politicians all
they care about is their money so they
can go buy some more [__] loafers
[__] stuff shirt
[__] um sorry dude I'm on the road
until [__] Monday with this now now
all of a sudden you know dude I had the
iro Z with the t-tops PW I took care of
her I polished her you know I got a nice
case and a nice [__] screen I don't
throw a thing around and I was it's just
it's like cars in the 80s when they made
them they were designed to [__] break
up at 60,000 so what frustrating but I
did go three and one Paul I'm and seven
Paul after four [__] weeks I got my
head above the water like Leo right
before he went under because that
[__] [__] wouldn't share the
mattress hey you know what you got a
six-game lead on me and you got a two
game lead on the book you are do well
I'm not competing against you I'd help
you move a [__] body I'm trying to
beat the book with you but you
historically you start slow like
Eli start slow you start coming on Mid
October well I got to give you credit
for something man everything you said
about that Bill's Dolphins game uh
especially with the you know I got you
said it exactly what was gonna happen uh
I looked at it like the Dolphins like I
said I had to see the hand because I
couldn't believe the Dolphins would fly
like that and then go in there and be
dogs let alone lose the way they did I
heard uh Jake The Snake I ran into Jake
The Snake Jake The Snake shout out to
Jake by the way coming to my show at the
Improv Jakey saw a good one uh but Ross
be anything better uh the ace R but he
said he was like I didn't even realize
the Dolphins didn't score in the second
half of that game
man Paul it's an entertainment League
you can't have the Dolphins going out
four games to none okay they had took
him a minute to rewrite the script it
was going to be Jetson bills and
unfortunately you know their QB goes
down Aaron Rogers so now they got they
gotta switch it around so dude I gotta
be honest when you start gambling you
think it's fixed why the [__] Patrick
Mahomes Runs Out of Bounds there because
I guess because to prevent defense they
would let him go the whole [__] field
in 18 seconds me it was the smart
football move because then they could
run out the clock but
meanwhile they would have covered and
Vegas would have lost their ass yeah
well are you telling me Paul these
mathletes with their algorithms and
their
computers figured out the D point of
that [__] game and that [__] he
was going to run out of bounds
there it ALS called stinks to high
heaven I think Taylor Swift is behind it
all um dude she's GNA be a
distraction yeah she is the whole time
she already is she already
is is she a
distract maybe the referees no to dumb
people I mean oh I mean like to dummies
like who just care about that give a
[__] if she's in the Box dude I got I
gotta [__] sprad to cover seeing her
jumping around with [__] cheese
sticks or whatever she was eating she's
eating funny about that [__] Paul that
reminds me of the Toronto Raptors when
they had the Super Fan right the guy
with the with with the turban or
whatever that guy went to every single
home and away game home and away game
when they sucked and they did all of
these things and the guy was a great guy
a positive guy yeah you just loved him
when you saw the interview then all of a
sudden the Raptors get good and Drake
starts coming around you used to call me
on your cell phone you
you and then they then they never showed
the guy again they never [__] showed
him again they went into the [__]
finals and you get to see this guy the
true Super Fan they didn't show him once
they showed Drake more than they showed
the [__] head coach of their own
goddamn team right that's what Taylor
Swift is gonna do to Patrick Mahomes
wife and she's gonna get upset she's
gonna be like oh p no they're already
jumbo as much they're already yeah yeah
but they're already friends she she's
she's already getting her in so she
could be part of it she knows how women
are they always start off as friends
Paul yeah goes off the rails the next
thing you know you lose a golfing buddy
dude I was uh I did I did K Adams I did
uh I did K Adams yesterday I went in
studio and I did the K Adams show and
she's like Paul we want to talk to you
about that you know the way the producer
comes in before you go on yeah bill I I
wish you saw her face the producer goes
on they go all right we want you to
obviously Paul we know how big of a
Giants fan you are we wanted we want you
to talk about Daniel Jones the offensive
line of the Giants then they go we want
you to talk about Bill bellich and um oh
dude you're gonna love this bill bellich
got broke up with his girlfriend before
the season does that have anything to do
with it like so then they go like this
I'm in studio and I'm sitting there and
I'm on TV and I'm with grank I'm with
grank grank is the GU me and grank goes
hey what's up Paul I'm like what's up
dude love you bye right so we're sitting
there and K Adams just goes K Adams goes
Paul so you know this whole thing bill
bich and his girlfriend we're finding
out his girlfriend and him broke up you
think that has anything to do to do with
it and I just go like this I go I go
okay I go it's a tale as old as time I
mean nobody takes down an Empire like a
woman dude her [__] face they just
went like this and the producers and
[__] grank was like this and then I
you know then it got so tense in there
that I go look I'm kidding I'm fighting
with my wife and gr's like dude I'm not
touching this
one grank goes I'm not touching this one
dude I got a message from the producer
going dude we were dying we were dying
because I was just being silly but um
but Daniel Jones they go do you want to
say anything to Daniel Jones he's gonna
be here tomorrow we'll play your
question for him and I go Daniel Daniel
listen to me how pissed were you when he
threw the tablet how bad did you want to
[__] shove it in I just got really
and she's like Paul unfortunately we
can't really give him that
question uh but the Giants are breaking
my heart the offensive line is horrible
and uh they're breaking my heart bill
but what are you do I'm a pat fan I'm
right there with you that was another
game I saw I I thought the Pats would
hang with the Cowboys for a half and
then what happened was gonna happen but
instead I don't think we even lasted
half of a first quarter we we went out
three to nothing reminded me of Super
Bowl 20 before the Bears destroyed us
and um you know dude like if you want to
argue M Jones isn't the guy I'd be all
right maybe that's it but he's not the
problem the guy's got no targets and
he's running for his life they brought a
zappy kid now he's running for his life
it's like we just gotta figure something
out which they will because it's Bill
bich they just they haven't figured it
out yet let's get to the picks here Paul
because I just recorded my [__]
Podcast Thursday when it's too [__]
quiet so I gotta do it again who has um
who has a first pick I think I do yep go
ahead all right I'm going to take the
New England Patriots playing the Saints
you know we're coming off a loss I think
the Pats despite uh our protection
issues is uh pton Manning used to always
say I say I think that we bounce back um
we're at home and I think the Pats are
getting one
Andrew yes getting one or or laying one
I don't give a [__] what is it they're
getting one they're getting one they're
getting one yeah I'm taking the Pats
getting one um I know it's a bit of a
[__] show with with between Jones and
zappy right now and uh I'm not paying
attention to that crap you know Bill
bich wins [__] games even with teams
like this and I think the Saints the
Saints aren't Marching In Paul I think
they're pointing in the wrong direction
I'm not saying they won't figure some
[__] out but they're not going to figure
it out this week I got the Pats getting
one at
home that's that's a W for
you um all right I'm going I'm gonna do
something I don't know if I've ever
picked this team since we've been doing
this show for two years I don't know if
I evered pick this team but they look
good and I'm going to take and and I
don't believe in the team they're
playing I'm going to take the the
Houston Texans on the road getting one
and a
half I just it's the it's the fal it's
the Falcons
right yeah Falcons scare me like they
came out of the blocks like looking
great and now they look like the Falcons
but the usual Falcons I I don't I I kind
of like if I had to bet that game I
don't know I kind of
I was like Atlanta going to turn it
around that's a ballsy pick though I do
like their Texans defense so I I think
that's uh Paulie Paulie you're waiting
into the Weeds on that one you know
right out the gate too you top pick and
I think I think that the Texans like the
little taste they got last week beating
up the Steelers like that and I I I've
seen enough from the Falcons to know the
Falcons could put up 17 points and then
just dip and lose at the end I'm going
to take the the Texans to pull that one
off so I got them uh one and I like it
all right I'm I'm going with the lady
that's been [__] uh that brought me
to the dance there I'm going with the
Ravens minus four playing the Steelers
in uh in
Pittsburgh um look I think the Steelers
are going to bounce back and play better
but I just feel like the
Ravens have the coach they have the
personnel and they're just in a way
better spot right now I you know I wish
it was [__] three and not four but I
just really believe that team there I I
think they are um you know if they stay
healthy they're definitely locked in to
make a nice playoff run I got the Ravens
laying four in Pittsburgh Paul one of my
favorite cities in the country me too
okay like that
pick look here's what I think about this
team the Cincinnati Bengals dude this is
it this is their season they're one and
three they're either going to write the
ship and go two and three or they are
dead and I don't know if burrow and them
could accept that I think minus three I
took them last time they were minus
three when I sat with you Bill and
watched that defensive line and they won
that game they know they got to win this
game it's only a field goal I'm gonna
take the bank I'm gonna take
Cincinnati that's funny because I like
the
Cardinals I just feel Kyler Murray is
gonna be [__] running he's like Barry
Sanders playing QB but I'm gonna stay
away from that one and I got two other
games here that I'm looking at Paul I
don't know where to go for some reason I
feel like the Chiefs are going to break
out against the
Vikings but I hate that number four
because the Vikings are good and they're
also at home then I got the Jets getting
two and a half against the [__]
Broncos dude how [__] nuts is that
stupid story have you seen that
story which I'm not gonna say who but
everybody know there there's a QB this
rumors going around that he banged his
mom's friend right yeah
yeah and here's what I love about that
story is it's people giving him [__] for
doing it and then also people giving him
props for doing it but no one's looking
at that woman going wait when did you
first meet
him like you banged him when he was 24
that was your mom's friend you [__]
pervert you know hey good on him I'm
just saying it's just funny how you know
the river one runs one way Paul nobody
question her or her [__] motives um
you know what Paul I think I'm going to
stay away from both of those and just to
keep this podcast interesting I'm going
to go head-to-head with you I'm going to
take the Cardinals laying uh uh getting
three I think that they've been playing
above their [__] pay grade the whole
year I don't think they're getting any
goddamn respect
and um I don't think that uh Joe burrow
is getting enough rest to make that calf
injury um ah hate [__] betting
against
him God damn damn it
um no you know what that feels like a
[__]
loss sorry about that and I don't like J
[__] this I'm taking the Chiefs minus
four I'm sticking with that I feel like
they have a Breakout game
right okay that's your so your third
pick is the Chiefs your second pick wait
a second so I got I got a dog and three
favorites I like a balanced attack
Paul
um yeah I three games I saw then the
other ones are just up in the air here
uh
you know
what I'm gonna go with the Jets [__] it
plus two and a half I'm gonna take Paul
didn't like that
one I'm gonna take the Jets plus two and
a half against the Broncos it doesn't
make any [__] sense yes it doesn't
make any sense to me that that you know
Russell is having this diff I just don't
like how the [__] do you it's like he
just it's like the that you know when
you're walking out in the surf and all
of a sudden it goes from like [__] 5
feet to 500 feet like how did that
happen Russell Wilson I just don't
understand it anyways all right Jets
plus two and a half Paul ver doesn't
like it but you don't like the Jets
either Paul no I wanted that game that
was my next
pick that's the [__] L Paul you know
I do anything for you but I can't do
that glasses are on Paul the pcks are in
well no wait a minute I'm only on my
third yeah bill that's it's not about
you when I put the glasses in it means
I'm [__]
no no you have one more yeah you still
got one more um no I don't yeah well you
changed from the Chiefs to the card I
thought that that was my fourth pick I'm
sorry all right with my third
pick I am gonna
take I was at Sofi last week for the
Chargers and the
Raiders and the Chargers started handing
it to the Raiders and with a backup
quarterback the Raiders started to play
play good play decent keep it to seven
think garoppolo's coming back I believe
the Raiders are home it's a onepoint
line the Raiders are getting one at home
which is basically a pick
them uh I think Jimmy G comes back and I
think the Raiders have a nice nice win I
think they end up you know trying to
write it a little bit at two and three I
I'm going to take I'm going to take the
Raiders plus one all right now that the
drama of me putting sunglasses on my
stupid little bit there is over I like
the
eagles in Sofi I think they had a tough
game last week they're going to have a
tough practice this week as much as I
respect the Rams and their
coach um Eagles laying four and a half
I'm going with them I
just I believe in them this year now
Paul now he puts the sunglasses
on dude if I go 0 and four I'm gonna be
I mean I'm like the Giants season if I
don't pull this one I'm like the giant
Paul have a question of confidence right
now this isn't the Paul ver we used to
Paul B we used to walks around he's got
his fur coat on with no shirt on
underneath this new Paul with his
windbreaker questioning everything he's
doing I'm not used to this he's got a
little money in his I used to have a
little money walking around money yeah
look at me I'm [__] sitting here like
the season's over I'm putting my
sunglasses on Paul I'm going a little
[__] WWE this year
well for my fourth and final
pick I am going to
take the San Francisco 49ers minus three
and a half against the Cowboys at
home uh game of the week dude I think
the 49ers are just too much I think
their defensive line is too much I think
their offense with do you think their
big biggest weakness on the 49ers is
their quarterback right now what do you
think about their head coach versus the
Cowboys uh I I I mean that's a tough one
but I think I like the punch right I
think I like the 49ers coach a little
better offensively than I like
McCarthy um you know I listen I wouldn't
touch three and a half if they were in
Dallas I think the crowd's gonna be
going nuts I think the defense is gonna
get to Dak and maybe make Dak make a
mistake I would really love the game if
it was three I don't love the the the
half a point think the key to that game
is Paul what's that 49ers got to be
playing with the lead the 49ers are
playing with the lead that kid py can
manage the game but if he has to play
catchup that Dallas D is gonna get a
pick I stayed away from that that game
made me nervous because I don't know
which way it's gonna go if Z him up you
know seven nothing or 10 to three and
that kid has to play catchup not saying
he can't do it I just haven't seen that
yet but he has the weapons if he's up to
manage that game and get the Victory but
that's the [__] game of the week
though right there you gotta you got to
say that this is the thing about me I
like to go in the deep water okay like
to jump in De it's a scary game afraid
Paul you're not a guy that you don't
live your life by fear listen it's a
scary game that's like I said I don't
like the half a point but I'm taking the
better team and I think it's the better
team on offense and defense and I think
it's the better Coach um I think the
49ers are a better team right now
because they're healthy I will tell you
though when they meet again in January
if the Cowboys are healthy on
defense
um you almost want to lose this game I
don't see I don't see either team
beating the other one twice you know who
said that what you just said gronowski
said that yesterday he goes I don't see
the 49ers losing he goes but I'm not
saying it's gonna be like that the whole
year he said what you just said hey Paul
you know that there's a reason why I got
my sunglasses on hey you're walking
reason 9 and seven Paul against the
[__] book after four weeks it just
say you know what Paul I slept with my
picks last week
I slept comfortably I didn't sleep with
them all right let's do okay Paul here
it is we came so [__] close last week
godd damn it was some injury or
something that killed us uh all right
everybody let the Monday night special
win some money for you for God's sake
let the Monday night special win some
[__] money for you no what
happened was that [__] [__] on uh the
goddamn Giants didn't score a touchdown
gin went down through a [__]
touchdown to
uh metf dude you see that guy's [__]
body [__] eats Skittles and
kitkats and [__] he looks like he's made
out of iron yeah but he's gonna [__]
when he's gonna blow out like Bernard
King when he's done dude Paul I always
ate [__] candy and [__] I never look
like
that he put whe powder on his Snickers
bar um all right
well I love I don't trust the f
FS I love this is my thing you do it I
mean hey I love Jimmy G to Devonte Adams
for a touchdown both of them throw one
catch one wait who's playing Monday
night oh no it's not the Raiders is it
it is Raiders yeah Packers Raiders I'm
sorry you started saying Atlant like
what's going on here I'm sorry not not
at Packers Raiders
in in Vegas means Packer fans like a
[__] Packers home game
um Devonte Adams though man the guy's
just well I saw him up close in personal
the guy's really good and Jimmy G loves
him as a Target so him him a touchdown
could him to him for a touchdown Jimmy G
to throw one and Devonte Adams to catch
one is like what gotta stop throwing
those late in the game interceptions
dude yeah but I think in the first half
he gets one for him I like that all
right so what do you want the third part
to be my thing I don't know [__] about
the Packers I know they got some new kid
love or something at quarterback right
and he seems to be doing okay win some
you lose some Paul hey the UPS Downs the
flows um yeah what's the
spread Raiders are getting one so it's
basically a pick
them and what's the over
under it's actually right now it's not
listed it looks like they might be uh
updating the lines um we're gonna we're
still gonna play it at the plus one but
I don't see it over you know what's
funny last week Paul when we took the
under I go yeah both those teams kind of
have good defenses and these [__]
[__] on the page is like actually uh
they don't have good defenses and you
could see that if you weren't wearing
those gay glasses well you know what I
think I saw it you [__] [__] came in
the under came
in deand did come in it did came in
easily with ease Paul I'm seeing 44 and
a half for the over under so that's like
an estimate I mean we'll
see know why I just feel like they're
GNA be flying around out
there let's do it like an entertainment
League Paul you know Thursday game was a
little [__] boring so I think they we
gotta light it up a little bit yeah a
little Frost's gonna put the call in
yeah yeah a little a little meeting with
the officials keep the laundry in the
pocket on this one yeah let him air it
out let him air it out it's good all
right all right so then the Monday night
special will be Jimmy G to throw one
Adams to catch one and over 44 and a
half so if there's D I love that I love
it I love that Paul I mean who are we
not as much as I love you but I I do
love that Paul Paul you're my original
Monday night
special all right that's it that's it
guys that is it thank you guys so much
go to the B MGM app put in $10 use bonus
code bur 200 you'll get it up to $200 in
bets regardless of the outcome of your
bet go to the suicide uh not the I keep
saying the suicide pool because that's
what we said when we were kids the
Survivor pool pick a team if they win
you eliminate that team and you keep
going and there'll be prizes at the end
bet responsibly enjoy this week football
and um we will see you next week